[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants j'espère que ce soir
tout est plus calme chez nos deux petits
amis nicolas et pimprenelle moi aussi je
l'espère pas trop et bien des envies de
voir nounours jules fonce pas trop où
est donc bon de cheveux mais dans ta
pâte gros nigo euh oui c'est vrai que je
suis dit qu au trot allant du courage
nounours oui du courage je veux hop hop
hop hop hop hop
ce pauvre nounours ça lui donne bien du
souci d'être tonton gouffre au réseau
tva ne nous besoin de nos choix autant
aimé petit veut j'espère tu son sort eh
bien tu vas voir enough
or hier tu veux voir il vaut mieux que
je m'emballe
on m'attend en eau vient nounours tiens
vous vient justement de manger oui très
proprement
[Musique]
et voilà tu vois tout où les cocos
évidemment ils ont fait un peu de tes
ordres
oui aux eaux
[Musique]
d'auto ou sont-ils dans ces petits jeux
peu inquiet peut-être dans le glac un
hall et qu aucun doute aux enfants y est
fait peut être honnête j'étais grande
rip non pas pr neil ils le font ça mc
graw db nous et ça nous mêmes à une
grogne canton appareils d ordre ah oui
maman elle ne gronde où tous mes petits
trésors
où êtes vous je vais voir dans la solde
de points sont peut-être sous la dalle
ne sont pas non je ne les trouve pas
mais où sont ils donc oui patron arrive
il est tard les enfants venaient je vous
accompagne ou un autre
non
il moi je ne veux pas là dedans
ous votre berceau petit job
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors du genre lui rue port vient pas me
remets au revoir nemours on va se
coucher dans un lit propres produits les
enfants lui ont reçu du bord
ce sont encore des plus plus
oh
le monde
[Musique]
bon
alan les petits enfants faites comme les
gentils neveu nounours et comme nicolas
et pimprenelle aller vite au dodo
d'ailleurs je suis sûr qu'ils dorment
déjà atteint c'est sûr patron ils sont
si mignons bonne idée enfants faites de
beaux rêves feu de bauer bonne
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]